welcome to the last couple of sessions
and now let me tell us about so hi
everyone so I know this is the evening
or the afternoon and on a Friday and
you're all tired of the workshop so I'm
going to keep it very light at least for
the first half of the lecture we'll go
into more details in the second half so
the goal of this lecture is to introduce
this generalization of real stable
formulas called completely lock on key
founders so
[Applause]
so so the best way I think of these
completely lock on Kaito meals is as
generating calm meals of distributions
okay so when we are talking about
distributions there are generally two
kinds of flavors of distribution if
there are continuous distributions and
discrete distributions for the purposes
of this talk we're gonna think of them
as density or our normalize density
functions on RN in the case of the
continuous distributions and on the
integer lattice in the case of discrete
distributions so to just keep things
simple you can also think of just
discrete distributions on the vertices
of the hypercube which you can also
think of as distributions on subsets of
1 through n vertices of hypercube are
basically the indicator vectors of sets
so so there are there are generally
three algorithmic things we want to do
with distributions the obvious one is to
sample from them so you have a non
normalize density given by an Oracle and
you want to produce a sample from it
very related to sampling is computing
the partition function so in the case of
continuous distributions that's like
integrating the function over the entire
space so that's what you have to
normalize your distribution by to get a
probability distribution and there are
very general reductions between these
two and I'm also going to talk a little
bit about optimization and by that I
mean finding the mode of this
distribution so so in the continuous
world there is a large class of
functions for which all of these three
operations are basically we are able to
do them using efficient algorithms and
that's the class of Lok concave
distributions so a la concave
distribution is just a density function
which when composed it lock is a concave
function or equivalently you have this
inequality on the bottom
so so it's one of the one of the
beautiful results in computer science
that you can more or less with minimal
assumptions efficiently produce a sample
from a lock-and-key of distribution just
using an Oracle function and these are
basically all based on
Markov chain Monte Carlo methods that
start from some point and then walk on
this space and converge to the
distribution represented by this
function so if you want to optimize such
a function or find the mode of a
distribution like this it's you can also
do this efficiently because finding the
mode is equivalent to finding the
maximum of the log of this distribution
and that's just a concave function so
you can do this by convex programming
methods so alright okay and we also know
a lot of examples in the continuous
world of La concave distributions my
favorite one is the indicator of a
convex set so this is a density that
sends the interior of a convex set to 1
and the exterior to 0 so you can just
easily verify that it satisfies the law
concavity there are other things like
the Gaussian density and there are
operations you can you can perform on la
concave distributions that preserve la
concavity so for example conditioning on
a coordinate or projecting onto a
coordinate all of these operations
preserve la concavity
so so the purpose of this talk is to
find an analogous class in the discrete
distributions so still we want to be
able to to do these things more or less
efficiently sampling counting and
optimization so so we want to basically
complete this picture so on the top I've
represented the distributions which we
also think of as density functions so
there are continuous densities and
discrete densities we also want the
analogy to work for the support
functions or the support sets of the
distributions okay so in the continuous
world when you have a lot concave
function its support is always a convex
set and the reverse is also true if you
have a convex set there is a there is a
lock on K distribution whose support is
that convex set that's just the
indicator of that convex so so I'm going
to argue that the analog of convex sets
should be matrix or matrix objects' and
then I'll tell you what what the vadet
version or what the densities should
look like any questions so far
so if you want to talk about La concave
discrete distributions perhaps the first
thing that you might think of is why not
just restrict the the la concavity
inequalities to just the lattice okay so
you have a function on Z to the N and if
this function was on the entire RN la
concavity would have meant well
concavity would have meant that you have
any qualities of this form that the
value of your distribution at any convex
combination is lower bounded by the
corresponding geometric convex
combination of the points and this is
still a valid inequality if the convex
you can still talk about this sort of
inequality and on functions whose domain
is the integer lattice as long as the
convex combination on the right hand
side is an integer point so you take
integer points you combine them as long
as you get an integer point you you you
can just impose this as an inequality on
yourself so the first proposal might be
okay let's let's talk about discrete
functions that that that basically
satisfy all inequalities of this form
and that's a very well studied property
when you were talking about functions
and the one-dimensional integer lattice
okay so on the one-dimensional integer
lattice functions are basically
sequences right and this condition
reduces to a local condition called la
concavity so you have a sequence
represented by this function and then
all of those inequalities reduce to
local inequalities of this form that for
every three consecutive members in your
in your sequence the middle one squared
should be bigger than the product of the
first and the third so so so first of
all at this this low concavity of
sequences is a very well studied and
well recognized property especially in
combinatorial there are many sequences
in combinatorics associated to community
objects that turn out to be la concave
so Alastair talked a little bit about
matchings of different sizes and graphs
so
Dooney ha proved that the coefficients
of the chromatic power which we have
also talked a lot about in this in this
workshop the coefficients of this
polynomial also turn out to be a lot
concave sequence and there are many many
more examples okay but the problem with
this definition is really when you go to
higher dimensions okay so if you think
of any function that's just supported on
the vertices of the hypercube it's going
to automatically satisfy all of these
inequalities that's because no vertex of
the hypercube is a convex combination of
the other ones so these are just not
telling you anything and certainly we
don't expect to we don't expect the
class as large as all functions on the
hypercube to be algorithmically
tractable so so let me just mention that
these lock concave sequences in the one
dimensional case it's been observed by
many groups of people that they they
sort of indicate shadows of something
called Hodge theory which I'm going to
talk about in the second a little bit in
the second part of this lecture so so
here are some other sequences of LOC and
here are some other la concave sequences
if you think of two convex sets and look
at the mixed volumes of them so you you
take the mixed volume of K&L with
different numbers of K and L repeated in
the sequence okay so as you vary Kappa
you get a sequence and the sequence
turns out to be LA concave and the Hodge
theory or the shadow of Hodge to be
associated with this la concave sequence
is the so-called poly tope algebra so
Roach's conjecture or the coefficients
of a generalization of the chromatic
formula of graphs this is another
sequence that has been proved to be la
concave by a do proceed to honkettes
this turns out to be related to a high
degree four matrix and then there are
other things let me just skip any major
sir all right so this la concavity of
sequences it works very well for
one-dimensional cases but when you go to
higher dimensions it doesn't really tell
you anything
so can we maybe perhaps try to
strengthen the de la concavity condition
and get something that generalizes to
higher dimensions so so here is here is
an approach so Newton basically knew a
set of inequalities that we now know by
Newton's inequalities he knew that if
you have a sequence of numbers and you
put them as the coefficients of a real
data as a as the coefficients of a
polynomial if the polymer turns out to
be real with it then the coefficients
are our la concave okay
moreover the coefficients divided by the
binomial coefficients are also locked
concave so this is slightly stronger
than simple la concavity this is called
ultra la concavity so this is what
Newton know in his time and fortunately
real witness is something that you can
generalize to higher dimensions and
we've already talked about it in this
bootcamp so the analog of real gudetama
meals in higher in in basically
multivariate formulas are real stable
formulas so let's let's do this cleanly
so when you're talking about the high
dimensional distribution on the integer
lattice you can associate a generating
palm oil to it the same way you did to
two one-dimensional sequences so what
you do is you basically take the take
your distribution and put them as the
coefficients of a multivariate formula
okay so to each integer point you can
you
can associate a monomial where the where
the coordinates of the integer point
appear as the powers so you just
multiply that by the value of your
distribution at the point and then sum
this over all points so this is a very
important definition please ask
questions if something is not clear so
then yeah so okay so for the purposes of
this talk we are only talking about
finite support distributions yeah yeah
that's correct
all right so so so Newton's inequalities
basically tell you that if this
Associated formula has real roots in the
Y dimensional case then the the
corresponding distribution is law
concave according to the previous
definition so of course we've already
talked about distributions whose whose
multivariate palm oils are satisfied
real stability which is the correct
organization of real goodness supports
here brandon and they get where the
first ones to study these kinds of
distributions and they named them
stronger in the distributions so so you
call a distribution on the hypercube
stronger ID exactly even its associated
follow me on is real stable and there
are many examples of these stronger ID
distributions I think Cheyenne has
already talked about the some of them
but just let me remind you a few so so
in the in the univariate case the
binomial distribution
the outcome of n coin tosses the number
of heads you see in M coin tosses so
that's a distribution who is Paul mule
is real rude and that's because you can
as you can factorize the Associated
generating formula in this way so
binomial distributions are are they are
basically the the most general things
that you can see in the univariate case
if you allow for for coin tosses to have
different biases
so another example is spanning trees in
a graph so you have a graph on M edges
and then you you map subsets of edges
that correspond to a spanning tree to
one and then the other subsets to 0 so
that's still a multivariate function and
it turns out that that's OCD Palmilla
love it is real stable so so so
determinant of points processes are
basically the main example of these
strangulated distributions and I know
that you've already talked about them
but let me just again remind you so you
have so you have a PSD matrix and then
you associate to a subset of 1 through n
the value that determinants of the
corresponding principal sub minor so if
you have a PSD matrix all of these
principal minors are also PSD and
therefore they have a positive
determinant so this is a positive
density on subsets of 1 through N and it
turns out that the Associated Palmilla
is real rooted and that's really under
the hood because you can write the
generating formula as a determinant and
real weirdness basically boils down to
the fact that symmetric matrices have
real roots have real eigenvalues
all right so okay so we have this class
of strongly Riley distributions it seems
like it it might be a generalization of
or it might be an analogue of law
concavity in the discrete case so can we
do the algorithmic things that we want
to do on this class turns out that the
answer is yes okay so so there are local
Markov chains that mix in polynomial
time
so these only need an Oracle for for
your distribution so you this this will
be talked about more during the semester
turns out that you can also do
optimization up to a certain degree okay
so there are algorithms to find an
approximation of the max of your
distribution the sort of approximation
that you should expect is of this form
to to the degree of your palm you okay
and so this is this is slightly
deviating from the continuous world in
the continuous world you can find the
exact maximum here you can't because
there are basically matching hardness of
approximation results but still this
sort of approximation is interesting and
I'll talk more about it
so okay so sampling implies that you can
also do counting but what about
deterministic counting so Corbet's whose
inequalities I think Cheyenne talked
about and maybe even in other talks
basically came up with a very beautiful
idea that when you have a real stable
poem or a strong value distribution you
can approximate its coefficients as long
as you have an Oracle access to to
something that evaluates the polynomial
for you so the sort of approximation you
can see is still exponential similar to
the optimization case and I'll tell you
a limit about a very distort of
exponential is coming from but if you if
you go a slightly beyond this
exponential you get one plus epsilon and
that's sort of like a reason why in all
of these cases you you either see an
exact algorithm of 1 plus epsilon
approximation or you see an exponential
approximation so there are
generalizations of this when you want to
find the maximum of the product of two
things but let me just skip that ok so
we have this class of stronger ideal
distributions and we can do these
algorithmic tasks for it efficiently but
the question is is it too restrictive
okay so so determinantal distributions
are sometimes called the the mother of
all strong unity distributions and
that's because in most applications you
always start from something
determinantal and then you apply maybe a
few operations to it and you get the
stronger a distribution that you care
about
there probably are things that are non
determinant of what are strongly but I
but in most applications everything
starts from something determinant and if
we really care about matrix which we
remember we wanted to be the support of
our functions strong really is not the
correct answer
okay so so one in one direction
Metroid's are the correct answer so
there is this result of coxless Ocala
and Wagner who showed that the supports
of stronger distributions are Metroid
so so supports our Metroid's always but
the reverse is not true Brandon showed
that there are Metroid's who support
which cannot be the support of any
stronger a distribution so it's easy to
construct matrix where the uniform
distribution is not strong really but
this is something stronger no way that
distribution can have the property of
being strongly
so alright so the main insight for for
generating a larger class who supports
our allmate roids is that in all of
these algorithmic tasks the property the
main property you're using is not real
stability but rather la concavity of the
polynomial right so so you so if you
remember if you have a hyperbolic
polynomial or a real stable poem you
know there is a region above its roots
so so here I'm drawing the roots of a
real stable poem you there is a there is
a region above the largest roots and
real stable polyols are known to be
basically a la concave barrier function
in this region and this region is known
to be convex
okay now the per meal that we care about
have non-negative coefficients because
they just they're just encoding
distributions right so the region above
their roots would contain the entire
positive or thent
okay so if G mu is stable then we know
that G mu is concave
or the entire positive or sent okay
and I I claim that in all of those
algorithmic primitives this is basically
the main property you need concavity so
so this suggests that maybe we should
just large in or enlarge our class of
formulas to just be the class of
formulas that are just la concave over
the entire positive or thend and that's
more or less what we are gonna do okay
so so this this observation that la
concavity is all that you need was
perhaps first so this observation was
perhaps first in the work of Corbett's
who generalized his inequality regarding
the coefficients of real stable poems to
Paula meals which have some sort of a
low concavity property so here is this
to to derive approximation algorithms
for mixed volumes and so on
oh I might mention that in the second
part let me not go into this work and
rather give you two simpler but more
illustrative applications where la
concavities you know yeah so you're
correct so what you need is something
called strong la concavity and I'll get
to that but for now bear with me just
for illustration because especially in
computer science community people won't
familiar with Boonen course yeah so to
mikorskis go concave nothing that we
will practice so sometimes you need more
than being course cases with you yeah
yeah so so just for now I'm not going to
mention about strong concavity means but
I'll get back to it yes yes concavity in
yeah so so what Leonid is saying is that
you have this ruining Karski inequality
which says that if you have a bunch of
a bunch of convex sets in some R to the
D then this part this thing so the
volume of z1 times k1 Minkowski sum with
G to k2 and up to the N times kN so
first of all this turns out to be a
polynomial and it turns out to be a lock
on K formul and that's exactly brooming
calfskin equality but what you need is
something slightly stronger than this
and I'll get back to what that stronger
property is ok so but but for now let me
just mention two simple applications
where all you need is just simple law
concavity not stronger concavity so the
first one is this optimization thing
that that I talked about so so you have
some distribution mu and you want to
find its mode okay and for just the
purposes of this illustration let's say
that you're your distribution is
supported on sets of size D so your palm
oil is the homogeneous okay so so that's
maybe the case when you're talking about
let's say K DPP's okay the terminal
point processes on supported on subsets
of K points so why do you want to do
this optimization it's it's very
relevant in machine learning
applications but maybe I can just show
you this picture and convince you so
here I'm trying to find K points inside
the square and the left I'm doing
uniform sampling on the right I'm using
the maximum of a KD PPE when when
basically the PSD matrix is given by an
RBF kernel on this space so as you can
see on the right the points are more
spread out and more nice okay so if you
if you want to do space exploration in
machine learning for example this might
be something but okay so how do we do
how we do how do we do optimization or
approximate optimization using just a
simple law concavity so so the the main
trick which is basically what nicole of
death is
you you do what every computer scientist
knows and loves and you you simply solve
a relaxation so the problem that you
want to solve is to compute the maximum
of your palm you'll evaluated at integer
points which sum up to D so if you if
you evaluate your palm you'll at the
indicator vector of a D set okay you get
exactly mu of that set right so you so
when you want to talk about relaxations
you simply drop the the constraint that
these should be integers and you you
solve this optimization over fractional
points that's some up to D okay so why
can't you solve this this relaxation
when you take its log it becomes a
concave program okay so if you're if
your palm oil has la concavity then
maximizing this is simply the same as
maximizing the log which you can do
because this is it's comfortable it's
concave right but now when you when you
found the point that maximizes this you
can simply round to a solution by
basically selecting a set with
probability proportional to basically
the product of the zi zenus so you you
find the maximum of that function that
gives you some z 1 through Zn and now
you you do this probabilistic rounding
where you select a set of abilities to
the product of the CIS now if you if the
probability was equal to this product
then the expected value of basically mu
of s would have been exactly the sum
over all s mu of s basically Z to the S
which is exactly your palm oil right
so if if there was no normalization
constant you would have by this rounding
procedure you would have gotten an
expectation the same as what you got
from the relaxation right but there is
of course a normalizing constant and
that's just the elementary symmetric
polynomial on the ice okay so you have
to basically this probability is is this
divided by e D of we want to okay and
this is exactly so over the over the
constraint set where everything sums up
to D this is at most e to the D so
that's how you get an e to the D
approximation and that's that's also
tight so that's basically what the
algorithm of Nikolov does and so this is
this is a probabilistic rounding but you
can make it deterministic by the method
of conditional expectations so so huh so
what I'm saying is that having that
expectation correct is not enough
because the probability that you the set
around 2 has a large value might be
small but you can you can get rid of
that okay so all right so for the second
application let me let me talk about
deterministic counting okay so so when
you want to when you want to when you
want to account so assume for now that
the distribution that you want to count
or you want to compute it's partition
function is the uniform distribution on
a subset of the hypercube
so for this application I'm assuming
that mu is uniform on some subset e of
the hyper key
okay and I'm also further assuming that
G mu is LA concave so when mu is uniform
on the on the on some subset the
partition function is the same as the
entropy of the distribution right so so
basically the so the entropy of your
distribution mu is going to be log of
the support size which is exactly a log
of the partition function so if you want
to count how large B is it's equivalent
to computing the entropy right and we do
have inequalities that upper bound entre
P so no matter what distribution you
have entropy has this property called
subadditivity which says that if you
project your high dimensional
distribution onto its marginal
coordinates so here I have a I have an
example of a distribution supported on
the two-dimensional hypercube when you
project it down onto the coordinates you
get Bernoulli to Bernoulli random
variables each of which you can just
represent using a number okay so the
entropy is always sub additive when you
do this this sort of projection if mu 1
to MU n are the marginals the the some
of them the some of them are the sum of
their entropies upper bounds on entropy
of your entire distribution so you can
think of it more or less as the fact
that an object basically lives in the
product of its shadows
so it turns out that when when this
panel is La concave you can prove that
the the upper bond you have over there
also becomes an approximate lower bound
and that's what I'm going to to prove
here
so so the proof of this is very simple
it's just a simple application of the
Jensen's inequality okay so we have this
G mu which is
so we have this to you which is la
concave
it's better
so you have this dream you which is la
concave and what I'm going to do is to
apply Jensen's inequality to each lock
okay so yes it's inequality all it says
is that log of G mu then you evaluate it
at a random point X all right
so when you take the expectation of it
this is basically a lower bound on log
of G mu when you evaluate it at the
expected points
right so that's the sort of thing I'm
going to that's the sort of inequality
I'm going to use and what what's a
natural random point so the the the main
ID so so the only basically natural way
to to plug in an X here is to choose a
random set or a random point from the
integer lattice according to mu and plug
it in here right so choose so let's say
Y is in 0 1 to the N and probability of
Y is given by B so the problem with
plugging in this simple or natural
choice y as for for for the random
variable X here is that on the right
hand side I get the expectation of Y but
really what I care about is computing my
palm at the all ones point not the not
the expectation of Y okay so the
expectation of Y is basically a vector P
1 through P n where P I is the
probability that I is in Y right it's
it's some fractional points whose
coordinates are between 0 and 1 and the
the fractions basically determine these
marginals that I've depicted the order
I care about evaluating my Palmilla at
the all ones point because that's my
partition function right so there is a
simple fix to this you just rescale each
coordinate so you basically let X be y1
divided by p1 up to yn divided by P n so
once I rescale like this the expectation
of X is going to be the all ones point
right
[Music]
so
so when I plug in when I plug in X into
the Jensen's inequality on the right
hand side I'm going to get log of my
partition function which is exactly the
log of the support size and on the left
hand side I'm going to get the
expectation so when I plug in something
which is a rescaled indicator vector of
a set into the poem ulg mu every term in
G mu disappears or cancels out except
for the term corresponding to that
particular set right Jimmy was was this
for me all right so Jimmy of Z 1 through
Zn was the sum over all these mu of T is
e to the T and when you plug in 0 s for
a Z for one of some of these the eyes
every set that doesn't contain those
disappears so in the end
there is only one set that's going to
remain and that's the set indicated by Y
so you're going to get basically yeah so
you're going to get basically the
product of one of our P is their eyes on
the Y coordinates of Y which are one
so sorry you have a log of this whole
thing so now this is a log of a simple
product you can turn it into a sum and
then split the expectation so what
you're going to get in the end is the
sum over I probability that Y I is equal
to 1 log of 1 over P I this is simply
the sum of the I log of 1 over P I so so
from la concavity of GMU we've gone
we've gone to an to a lower bound for
its partition or the log of its
partition function which looks awfully
like the sum of the marginal entropy x'
right in the sum of the marginal
entropies there is only one term which
is missing here in the sum of the
marginal entropy is you have this extra
term
so what you can show is that whenever
the P is sum up to D this term also sums
up to at most D so the term that you're
missing from the sum of the art marginal
on trapeze is exactly at most the degree
of genial so so that's how you prove
such an inequality so this inequality
you can basically interpret as saying
that when you have a when you have a
distribution whose polynomial is LA
concave it's not too far from a product
distribution because for product
distributions you have an inequality you
have an equality between the two sides
and this is saying that that equality is
almost satisfied something like this is
also true in the continuous case yes so
I think you get that you get exactly the
dimension of the function here
okay so so what we've done is so far
I've only told you an inequality but
what we care about is really counting
and and I haven't still given you an
algorithm for counting because computing
these marginals is just as hard as the
counting from the counting problem
itself so turns out that there are some
tricks that you can do to to get a
counting algorithm out of this for for-4
subsets of the hypercube who is
polynomial is la concave and we're gonna
see later in this talk that matrices are
a special case of this so here is a
quick refresher on Metroid's so a major
is basically a family of sets or subsets
of 1 through n that we're gonna call the
independent sets so it has to satisfy
two properties downward closure is the
is the fact that when you have an
independent set any subset of it is also
independent and the more important one
is this exchange axiom which says that
if you have two independent sets one is
larger than the other one there is
always something from the larger set
that you can add to the smaller one and
still be independent so I know that
you've seen this a little bit in the
previous talks but yes the refresher so
this second property implies that when
you look at maximal independent sets
they must all have the same size that
size is also called the rank of the
matrix
so what we're going to prove is that
when you have a mate right when you look
at these maximal independent sets or the
uniform distribution and these maximal
independent sets the corresponding
polynomial is LA concave
[Music]
so when you are looking at the basis of
a mate right it's corresponding
polynomial is going to be exactly this
the sum over all bases the product of
elements in the base and we are going to
show that this is always law concave
so so there are many examples of mate
roads maybe the one that you should have
in mind is the case of a linear mate
right so you have vectors in some field
or in vectors in some vector space over
some field and then you call a subset of
them independent if they are linearly
independent so mentors are basically an
abstraction of this notion of linear
independence and Counting bases in
Metroid's is an important problem let me
let me just give you a few examples so
counting basis of independent set or
counting basis or independent sets of
matrices allows you to do things like
compute the probability of recovery in
codes okay so in coding theory you have
these these things called
error correcting codes which are usually
the kernels of some matrix over some
finite field okay so you have you have a
matrix usually a white matrix and you're
looking at the kernel of it as as
basically words in your code turns out
that if if you send some word like this
which is in the kernel of this matrix
and if some of the bits get corrupted
and get erased you can recover them
exactly when the corresponding columns
in this matrix are linearly independent
okay so so being able to count basis or
independent sets in my choice allows you
to compute the probability that you can
recover from ratios of this form so you
can also do graph reliability so so
imagine that you have a graph and you're
looking at subsets of exactly K edges
which form a connected subgraph these
turn out to be bases of a matrix
okay so when K is equal to n minus 1
this is the usual graphic metroid' that
people love when K is bigger than n
minus 1 this is basically the union of
the graphic metroid' and a uniform a
tree so being able to count the number
of bases in in this Metroid allows you
to compute the probability that when
your edges fail with some probabilities
your
Graff remains connected and then let me
let me skip this in the interest of time
there's there's also these rigidity
matrix which basically corresponds to
structures which are rigid so so if we
know that there is a metroid whose
families lock concave we know many
instances of matrix where the pommel is
real stable for example so we already
know some Metroid's where where we know
the corresponding polynomial is locked
concave how do we turn this inequality
into a counting algorithm so the way we
are gonna do that is we don't know
exactly what the eyes are so we can't
just compute the sum of the marginal
entropies and use that as our
approximation but what we do know is
that these pis
fall into a certain region of their
space which we which we have access to
algorithmically so so the the vector of
PI's is exactly the expectation of the
indicator of a B where B is chosen a
course where B is basically uniformly
random
right so now if you look at all of the
indicator vectors of these bases they
form some subset of the hypercube so we
know that this vector of P is is exactly
the average of all of these vectors
right which is going to be a point
inside the convex hull of all of them
right so we know some rough location for
this vector P and what you can do is
basically take the worst possible case
for the upper bound and find the maximum
of the sum of the marginal entropies and
where basically P 1 through P n is in
this rough set that we know
okay so this still gives you an upper
boundary because we took a pessimistic
bound right but turns out that the same
level actually holds okay so if you if
you if the eyes are the maximizers of of
that that program if your eyes are the
maximizers of that program then you
still have the corresponding lower bound
inequality so here is a proof of that so
so I think again
Cheyenne talked about this when you have
points inside a convex hull there is
always some external field that you can
apply to your distribution to to get
exactly those marginals okay so what I
mean by that is that there exists some
set of numbers lambda 1 through lambda n
such that if you if you basically define
or says so if you define an alternative
distribution rather than the uniform
distribution on basis you you sample a
set s with probability proportional to
the product of these lambda i's
so if lambda are all one this is again
the uniform distribution on on the set
of bases but I'm allowing an external
field and I'm allowing more some
elements to be more likely to to be in
the set than the others so there exists
a set of lambda ice such that when you
sample your s according to this the
probability that I is in s is exactly P
I
so so this again correspond to two
computing the capacity like equal the
capacity like quantities and stuff like
that but for now take it as given okay
so when you have a distribution like
this the modified distribution so so
let's call this distribution new so
sample according to new
where the probability of nuova set is
given by that
then the par meal for new is some simple
modification of the POW meal form you
write or this is proportional to MU of
lambda 1 z 1 up to lambda n Z so does
everybody see this
so I'm sampling basis for now for for
now I'm just doing matrix but you can do
this for for more general cases so so so
the par meal for new is basically a
simple modification of the palm oil from
you I basically scale it coordinate by
lambda I and the thing to observe here
is that this sort of a transformation
preserves law concavity any affine
transformation and the inputs which
preserves the positive or thent
preserves law concavity so now by the
law concavity of the polymer for new I
can again apply this inequality this
time to new instead of mu and get that
the entropy for new is bigger than the
sum of the entropies of new eyes -
basically the where D is the size of my
basis or the rank of M now the entropies
of new are exactly the entropies of p is
because I chose my new to have exactly
the marginals
which maximize the the value were there
so did you want to multiply the mu of s
up there by the lawndale's
the second line up there the second line
oh yeah I mean sure so so because my my
distribution was uniform I dropped this
there but yeah so okay so just from the
property that that G mu is LA concave I
concluded that G nu is also a concave
now I applied my entropy lower bound to
Nu and I get an entre P lower bound for
new so I get this inequality but the
thing to observe here is that the
entropy of MU is also an upper bound for
the entropy of new okay that's because
when you're talking about distributions
over a set the uniform distribution over
that set is the one that maximizes the
entropy so nu is some crazy distribution
this one is the uniform distribution so
it has a higher entropy so so I again
get exactly the same lower one as I
wanted for the entropy of new even
though my marginals don't exactly
correspond to the marginals of you so
that's another application where law
concavity basically helps you in
counting yeah yeah you also don't need
to compute the lambdas gradient the
gradient of one one no no no it's not so
the gradient of the log is is exact is
the exact marginals right here I'm just
maximizing the sum of if you take the
exact marginals they are the gradient of
the log but these are not the exact
motions
all right so okay so so there has been a
lot of talk about the la concavity of
these columns for may Troy's but I
haven't told you why that that is true
so so okay so so there is a there is a
basically fundamental reason that real
stability wasn't able to capture all
Metroid's
and that's that's because when you're
talking about stronger idea
distributions or real stable
distributions they have this property
called negative correlation okay so so
if if you have let's say a may try it
again and you're looking at random basis
of it that means negative a negative
correlation means that when you take two
elements inj the probability that both
of them are in your random base is upper
bounded by the product of the
probability that each individual 1s
right so so to appreciate what this
means when you have an independent
distribution over over over things you
have equality here this is saying that
you are basically sub independent you
have negative correlation so every
stronger distribution has this property
and in fact the funny story that at some
point in the past people had conjectured
that this also holds for all matrix a so
see more and dollish conjecture that all
mate roids or random basis of my toys
have this property turns out that they
don't took them a few years to find a
counter example because they didn't have
basically access to computer simulation
I assume so nowadays if you just
generated a simple linear Metroid you
can exactly you can find counter
examples to this very easily
but but like I said they the power meals
for these matrix turn out to be la
concave and they also turn out to
satisfy some other property which real
stable paw meals satisfy so the real
stable Paulo meals have all of the three
properties I'm I've listed here negative
correlation la concavity and being
closed on their directional derivatives
for meit Rhodes experiments at least
showed that when you take a bunch of
direction other everything's the end
result is always going to be LA concave
so not just like the polynomial that you
start with but when you take derivatives
a few times you're gonna still come to a
lock on a palm you know so that's that's
what we are going to base our definition
on so the properties that empirically we
observed
hold for matrix being LA concave and
being closed under the direction of
there it is so so this is the this is
the definition we are going to use for
the for the second part of the lecture
you call some polynomial lock on
completely la concave if after you take
any number of directional derivatives of
it in positive directions the end result
is going to be LA concave okay so I
should mention that this is very much
inspired by a similar definition of
Gurewitz
who basically defined polyols to be
strongly la concave when when the same
thing holds when you're taking only
partial derivatives right yeah so so so
so okay so let me let me elaborate
so Courbet's basically used the fact
that this this volume power which I
raised okay so the the thing that
corresponds to the minkovski the
Minkowski sums of convex sets and the
bringing cost gain equality so that
thing he observed that it satisfies all
of these inequalities okay and then that
was the the thing that that he used to
derive inequalities on the coefficients
of this problem
so later on we are gonna see that this
is actually not that much of a different
definition this is exactly equivalent to
stronger concavity so in this definition
you can actually replace everything by
partial derivatives so i doing on time
is it okay to go
all right so so the exercise so my worry
is that the exercises don't make much
sense if I don't get to the next slide
so perhaps I can just use the the maybe
we can take a five-minute break I can go
over this and then do the exercises at
the beginning of the second we had this
inequality for real civil palms and then
[Music]
but what distribution